WHY THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL OF
KYIV IS IN SO MUCH DANGER
TONIGHT.
WE'RE JOINED BY CNN'S JOHN KING
ALONG WITH FORWESLEY CLARK.
THE U.S. IS DEEPLY CONCERNED
THAT KYIV, THE CAPITAL, COULD
FALL TO THE RUSSIANS WITHIN A
FEW DAYS.
>> I'LL SHOW YOU WHY AND ALSO
USE THE MAP, THE VALUE OF THE
MAP.
THE GREAT LIVE REPORTING FROM
OUR BRAVEST CORRESPONDENTS.
IN KYIV, THE CAPITAL UNDER
ASSAULT.
SAM KILEY AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN
HERE.
KHARKIV.
AND THE ARROWS DOWN HERE, THE
SCOPE OF THIS SHOWS YOU THE
RUSSIANS ARE QUITE SERIOUS.
YOU HEAR FROM THE PENTAGON AND
UKRAINIANS ABOUT THE RESISTANCE,
YOU ALSO HEAR THE RUSSIANS ARE
ACCELERATING THEIR ATTACK ON THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
THIS IS ABOUT THE SIZE OF TEXAS.
AMPHIBIOUS INFANTRY IS THE
RUSSIAN JARGON FOR MARINES
COMING IN HERE AND GROUND TROOPS
FROM CRIMEA TOWARD THE DONBAS.
AND THEN YOU MOVE UP HERE.
THERE'S FIGHTING DOWN HERE AND
THEN KYIV, THE CAPITAL.
OBVIOUSLY SEIZING THE STATE OF
POWER WOULD BE CRITICAL.
I WANT TO BRING US IN CLOSER TO
THIS.
YESTERDAY OUR MATTHEW CHANCE
SAID HE LEFT KYIV AND WENT UP
HERE TO THE NORTHWEST TO ANTONOV
AIRPORT.
HE BELIEVED THEY WERE SPECIAL
OPERATIONS FORCES.
TODAY THE RUSSIAN DEFENSE
MINISTRY WENT PUBLIC AND SAYS IT
NOW CONTROLS THIS KEY AIRPORT.
YOU SEE THE PROXIMITY TO KYIV
AND GENERAL CLARK, WANT TO BRING
YOU IN ON THAT POINT.
JUST TO MAKE THE POINT, THIS IS
NOT YOUR ANY RUN OF THE MILL
AIRPORT.
THIS SAN AIRPORT WITH LONG AIR
STRIPS WHERE YOU CAN LAND
MILITARY TRANSPORT PLANES.
IF THE IDEA IS TO TAKE KYIV, WHY
IS THAT SO IMPORTANT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
I MEAN, THEY WANTED TO HOLD THAT
AIRPORT.
THEY WANTED TO SEIZE THAT
AIRPORT SO THEY COULD AIR LAND
PARATROOPS IN THERE AND GRAB THE
KYIV AND ADD TO THE SIEGE THAT'S
GOING IN AROUND KYIV.
>> AND SO, WOLF, YOU GET THE
SENSE THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE
TARGETS.
GENERAL CLARK HAS BROADER
PERSPECTIVES ABOUT WHAT HE
BELIEVES IS A DIRE DAY.
>> AND REALLY REMARKABLE MOVE.
NATO FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE IT
WAS ESTABLISHED BACK, WHAT,
1949, IT HAS ACTIVATED WHAT IT
CALLS THE NATO RESPONSE FORCE.
>> LET ME BRING THIS UP AND
GENERAL CLARK, ONCE THE NATO
SUPREME ALLIED COMMANDER CAN
HELP US WITH THE CONTEXT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MAP FROM
THIS.
ALL THE BLUE ARE NATO COUNTRIES
THAT SURROUND.
THIS EMERGENCY NATO RESPONSE
FORCE HAS NEVER BEEN ACTIVATED
TO PROTECT NATO COUNTRIES.
IT WAS ALWAYS USED TO PROJECT
FORCE ELSEWHERE.
THE SECRETARY-GENERAL SAYING IT
COULD BE DEPLOYED.
COULD BE UP TO 40,000 TROOPS.
GROUND TROOPS AND AIR AND SEA.
NOT THE FULL FORCE BEING
DEPLOYED NOW.
BUT THE UNITED STATES AND OTHER
NATO ALLIES HAVE SENT MORE
TROOPS TO ESTONIA, LATVIA,
LITHUANIA, POLAND.
YOU SEE THE NATO RING HERE.
LOOK WHERE UKRAINE IS.
WHEN WE STARTED THIS WEEK,
RUSSIA HAS A PUPPET GOVERNMENT
IN BELARUS BUT HERE WAS THE LINE
ESSENTIALLY.
THESE NATO COUNTRIES HAD A
BUFFER.
UKRAINE.
IF VLADIMIR PUTIN TAKES UKRAINE
AND THAT GOES AWAY, ESSENTIALLY
WHAT YOU GET IS 33 YEARS AFTER
THE FALL OF THE BERLIN WALL,
VLADIMIR PUTIN GETS TO EXTEND
PERHAPS A NEW IRON CURTAIN RIGHT
THERE ON NATO'S DOORSTEP.
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE SO CONCERNED
ABOUT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, JOHN.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT IT, BUT I'M
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE PEOPLE
IN KYIV.
FOR -- SINCE REALLY SINCE HARRY
TRUMAN, PROVIDED ASSISTANCE TO
GREECE FIGHTING A COMMUNIST
INSURGENESSY IN 1947, THE UNITED
STATES HAS HELPED COUNTRIES
DEFEND THEIR INDEPENDENCE.
IN KYIV, WE'VE GOT 40 MILLION --
IN UKRAINE, 40 MILLION PEOPLE
WHO HAVE AN INDEPENDENT COUNTRY.
I'M LOOKING AT KYIV ITSELF.
IT'S GOING TO BE BESIEGED.
IT'S UNDER ARTILLERY FIRE AND SO
FORTH.
YOU HAVE OVER 2 MILLION PEOPLE
IN THERE.
AND THE ORDERS THAT PUTIN HAS
GIVEN APPARENTLY IS TO BESIEGE
IT AND CLEAR IT.
AND THAT MEANS UNQUESTIONABLY
HUNDREDS, MAYBE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CIVILIAN
CASUALTIES.
AND FOR NATO, THAT'S FINE.
WE'VE ACTIVATED THE REACTION
FORCE.
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING IN TO
UKRAINE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING
FOR THOSE PEOPLE.
SO IN MY LIFETIME, WHAT I'VE
SEEN IS THE UNITED STATES HELPS
NATIONS DEFEND THEMSELVES
AGAINST EXTERNAL AGGRESSION.
AND WE'RE ASKING, WHAT CAN WE
DO?
THE SANCTIONS ARE GREAT, BUT
WHAT CAN WE DO TONIGHT,
TOMORROW, THE NEXT DAY, TO HELP
UKRAINE AND UKRAINIANS HOLD ON
TO THEIR INDEPENDENCE AND STOP
THE IMPENDING SLAUGHTER IN KYIV.
>> WOLF, YOU CAN HEAR FROM
GENERAL CLARK THERE, HE MAP OF
KYIV.
IT'S BETWEEN THE SIZE OF CHICAGO
AND LOS ANGELES.
NEARLY 3 MILLION PEOPLE.
NOT ONLY THE SEAT OF GOVERNMENT,
A GIANT METROPOLITAN CITY.
THE LARGEST CITY IN KYIV UNDER
SIEGE.
>> LET ME ASK GENERAL WESLEY
CLARK, WHAT CAN THE U.S. DO AND
NATO ALLIES?
THERE ARE 30 COUNTRIES THAT ARE
MEMBERS OF NATO RIGHT NOW.
WHAT CAN, WHAT SHOULD THEY BE
DOING TO SAVE THE LIVES OF THOSE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN UKRAINE
WHO POTENTIALLY THE NEXT DAY OR
TWO COULD BE KILLED?
>> WELL, THAT'S THE QUESTION.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD GO TO THE
UNITED NATIONS.
WE SHOULD CALL ON RUSSIA TO DO
AN IMMEDIATE HALT OF ITS
OPERATIONS.
WE SHOULD DECLARE A SAFE ZONE
AROUND KYIV AND MAYBE EVERY PART
OF UKRAINE, WEST OF THE RIVER.
TELL RUSSIA TO HALT.
TELL THEM TO STOP.
THEY DONT HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO
THIS.
AS PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID, THIS IS
ILL
ILLEGAL.
AND THE SANCTIONS ARE PUTIN ARE
GREAT.
BUT I REMEMBER BEING IN THE
BALKANS AND WHAT THAT HARDSHIP
WAS.
AND YOU DO, TO